hey youtubers it's Charlie since we've
finally gotten past the Christmas
special and series eight is getting
ready to film next week I thought it was
time to do a predictions video there's
actually a lot of things that we already
know so I'll be including all those
things first and then I'll talk about my
top five predictions also heads up my
plan for the next couple of months is to
do at least one Doctor Who video every
week it'll either be like a fun bonus
video or something about the production
behind the scenes or like a fun Q&A
video if you guys have specific
questions that you want to ask me be
sure to subscribe to get everything so
here we go number one filming for series
8 episode 1 starts on Monday January 6
they only have half of the episodes
planned out which is 6 so they'll finish
the scripts for the second half of the
season and lockdown directors and
stories while they're making those first
batch of episodes to all the episodes
will air week to week without a giant
break like series 7 raise your hand if
you hated that break during series 7 3
there will be 13 episodes and possibly
an Easter special no Christmas special
has been confirmed yet for returning
characters include the Paternoster gang
that's vastra Jenny and Strax
and of course claw but Alex Kingston has
also said that she might be coming back
to she posted a video back in October
with her classic spoilers line remember
her character's relationship with the
doctor spanned multiple versions not
just Matt Smith's doctor so it would
totally be in keeping with Canon for her
to interact with Peter Capaldi 5 the
first episode will feature vostra Jenny
and Strax six blue Peter ran a
competition to design a few sonic
screwdrivers for each of them to use in
that episode
can you imagine Strax with a sonic
screwdriver 7 even though there are a
few characters returning Stephen Moffat
has said in his own words that he's
cleaning house meaning that a lot of the
anachronism zuv Matt Smith's era won't
be there so if there were a lot of
things that Matt Smith's doctor did that
you did not like they will be gone at
series 8 number 8 the directors that
have been announced so far include Ben
Wheatley who's doing the first episode
Paul Murphy and Douglas MacKinnon
they're each doing two episodes
thus the six that they're starting to
shoot on Monday number nine the writers
currently the writers that have been
hired back are mostly familiar face
is not including steven moffat who's
writing the first episode they include
Mark Gatiss Neil cross and Gareth
Roberts currently in talks for those
other six episodes are Christian bull
Tom McCrae Jack Lothian and possibly
Neil Gaiman although he said doctor who
doesn't pay very well and the last
episode he wrote nightmare in silver was
supposed to be a two-parter and got
smashed down into one episode which
everybody kind of agreed was a bad idea
so don't be surprised if he doesn't
return and number 10 the premiere will
be after August no official date yet but
we could see episodes by the end of
August or September at the latest okay
so time for predictions here we go
number one the Time Lords they tried to
contact the doctor successfully via the
cracks that idea of them trying to bring
back Gallifrey will be part of the
larger narrative they'll still be stuck
in that pocket universe but because the
Daleks know what's going on now there's
the constant threat of resuming the time
war so series 8 will probably end with
them still stuck outside the universe
but they'll still be able to say
telephone the doctor using the cracks
second something else is going to try
and break into the universe if the Time
Lords can do it then so can something
else that's really awful but because
Steven Moffat is changing a lot of
aspects of the show don't expect it to
be a classic villain like the master or
another one of the time-lock races that
David Tennant mentioned during the end
of time but that doesn't mean that
that's an impossibility so the
opportunity to bring back one of those
classic villains is still there number
three
the doctor will leave Clara by the end
of the series meaning I expect to see a
new companion during series 9 right now
both Capaldi and Jenna Louise Coleman
are only signed on for series 8 but I do
expect Capaldi to return number four
there will be a new original villain
Steven Moffat created the silence during
series 6 to be the main villains he'll
do the same type of thing again in
series 8 typically new baddies get
introduced in that first episode since
it will be a brand new doctor's first
episode it could be like an 11th hour
situation where it's more of a mystery
that's introduced in that first episode
and number 5 the cracks will still be
there Matt Smith's doctor said that when
he fixed the universe it left a
fundamental weakness which is where the
cracks come from he never fixed that
weakness before regenerating so it will
still be a very big issue those cracks
will not only allow the Time Lords to be
part of the story
allow other things from outside the
universe to be part of the story to so
expect something really awful to break
back into the universe okay I know I
mentioned River Song earlier and she's
more for prediction but because she
already shot a video and used her
classic spoilers line I think we can
bump her from you know maybe gonna be in
series eight to probably two spoilers
but because the character was kind of
left in limbo at the end of series seven
we have no idea how her character's
going to manifest during series 8
whether it be you know as a spirit or as
a physical person let me know below in
the comments what you think about the
idea of River Song returning and whether
you'd rather see say like a classic
villain return or whether you want to
see a new original villain as I said
before I'll be doing weekly Doctor Who
videos going forward be sure to
subscribe to get them and if there's
anything really specific that you want
to talk about just let me know in the
comments right now you can click here to
get my Christmas special Easter eggs and
you can click here to get my review for
the first episode of Sherlock series 3
it was so much fun thank you for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you